لكن ما هي الخيارات امام الرئيس ماكرون
لتهدئه موجه هذه الاضرابات وايضا
الاحتجاجات التي تحولت لمواجهات عنيفه مع
الشرطه في الايام الماضيه رغم فشل الاحزاب
المعارضه في حجب الثقه عن حكومه اليزابيث
بورن الا ان هذا لا يعني بان المعركه
الهادفه لاسقاط قانون التقاعد قد انتهت
قررت نقابات العمال والمعارضه تنظيم يوم
احتجاجي جديد غدا طبعا للضغط على ماكرون
ولحثه على سحب القانون المثير للجدل هناك
خياران امام المعارضه احدهما اللجوء الى
المجلس الدستوري طبعا للنظر في شرعيه
وقانونيه القانون او اللجوء الى تنظيم
استفتاء شعبي لحسم هذه القضيه مع ذلك بعض
المتتبعين لسياسه يعتقدون انه في حال اراد
ماكرون العوده الى وسط اللعبه عليه اي
يتخذ بعض القرارات الجريئه كسحب القانون
او تعيين حكومه جديده والا فانه سيواجه
مشاكل كثيره في البرلمان من اجل تمرير
قوانين اخرى قانوني الهجره والعمل الذين
سيطرحان للمناقشه في الايام او الاشهر
القليله المقبله